let's say a group of Georgia Southern
filmmakers your alma mater had made a
bunch of short films and had yet to make
a feature so they're all from your
school and maybe you're going to address
the class and give them advice what
would you tell them about distributing
short films compared to distributing a
feature film or maybe there's absolutely
no comparison there I think there is a
comparison to be had I actually have had
this conversation my students at Georgia
Southern I'm on the Advisory Board so I
go back periodically to talk and one of
the things that I think the different
share between distributor short film and
distributing a feature film is MA ties
because a short film in general if you
do it right you don't really have to
monetize it unless it's a you know fifty
thousand dollar effects driven thing
that you want CAA to watch that's a
different kind of project but if you're
making a standard short film or web
series or something of that nature like
I said earlier distribution is not as
much of an issue I don't think because
you're just trying to attract attention
but when you make feature film there's
money involved and when there's money
involved distribution is extremely
important because if you don't have a
distribution plan pathway or someone to
purchase the picture someone's going to
lose a lot of money and if that someone
loses a lot of money it's not very good
for your career
so let's take that $50,000 short film
let's say is now their second film that
they want to make a short film are you
advising them to do that and they want
to tour the festival circuit with it
does that make sense I think it depends
and I know that's not a clear-cut answer
long and short answer I don't think that
most people were equipped to go make a
$50,000 visual effects driven short film
that they're going to take to film
festivals and try to get the attention
of a major agency to sign them to a
studio picture that's going to be a
multi-million dollar event film there
are examples but I think they're very
few if you start quantifying the number
of people that get to do that versus the
number of people that actually attempt
it I think at the end of the day you're
better served unless you happen to be a
visual effects genius and if you are
more power to
you go do it but if you do not have the
capacity or the skills to do some of
that yourself
spend the money in other ways you can
make a $50,000 feature film instead of
your $50,000 short visual effects driven
film that might enable you to do
something better that you probably could
monetize by selling it yourself and put
yourself in a better position to advance
your career would you say there's a cap
on what someone should spend on a short
film you know let's say this is their
second film and they're they're hoping
to do that they're hoping to tour the
festival circuit with it and and and get
the attention is there is there like a
minimum or excuse me a maximum it's like
no more than 10,000 even though that is
still a lot of money
III think that there isn't such a thing
as a maximum you should spend on a short
film but I think there's a maximum you
should spend as to what you can afford
and as to what your story needs to serve
it well I think that when you're making
a short or even a micro budget feature
for that matter whatever it is you
always need to treat your budget as what
is the lowest amount I can make this
film for that will best serve the story
and not for my attempt to make it the
best I can and that doesn't matter what
you're trying to make but whatever it is
make sure you can afford it because say
for example you do spend ten thousand
dollars on that short film you've made
the short film but that's not the end of
your expenses is it now you have Film
Festival submissions say you get into
some festivals you probably want to go
to those festivals to network to meet
other producers to meet other filmmakers
to do some press for it to do the things
that are going to give your movie
attention how much money did you budget
for that did you not budget money for it
now you have another couple thousand
that you've added to your total budget
those are things that you have to ask
yourself at the onset and if you only
have ten thousand dollars to make the
film that isn't just production that's
all of those other fees that come with
it
so you really have to think what is the
lowest amount I can tell this story
effectively at so I can enable
self to get to my next goal hmm but then
have more money in reserves or maybe if
it's going to be a year before you
actually finish the project have that
ready for press you know festivals you
know maybe even hiring a publicist they
sure factor that in and those are all
factors that any filmmaker that takes
their career seriously should consider
now if you're just doing this amateur if
you just want to make films because you
like doing it as a hobby you don't need
to worry with all that but if you want
to be a professional filmmaker if you
want to be a professional writer
director actor those are factors you
absolutely have to account for
you